Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, je réponds à une question
de Stéphanie, qui est anichinabée, qui me demande :
« Maintenant qu'on parle beaucoup
de réconciliation, comment peut-on organiser
celle-ci et, surtout, comment on peut
le faire en respectant et en gardant
la reconnaissance
de nos droits. »
Stéphanie, c'est une question qui est extrêmement importante, une question qui va être très dur à répondre
en une seule solution parce que c'est une
des raisons pour laquelle on s'est mobilisés
pendant la période d'Idle No More il y a
quelques années. Les droits ancestraux,
la reconnaissance de ces droits-là,
dépend vraiment d'une chose.
C'est-à-dire, de connaître les droits.
Premièrement, de s'intéresser à la Loi sur les Indiens,
de s'intéresser à la Constitution canadienne,
de s'intéresser aussi aux droits
qui se présentent devant la Cour suprême,
parce que ce n'est pas des droits qui sont
accordés par le gouvernement canadien,
mais ce sont des droits qui sont reconnus par eux.
Ces droits-là existent depuis avant
l'arrivée des Européens, avant le premier contact.
C'est pour ça qu'on dit
« droits ancestraux ».
C'est qu'ils ont continué d'exister
depuis le premier contact, jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Pour pouvoir les organiser
il faut les connaître il faut les pratiquer, aussi.
D'ailleurs, c'est pour ça
qu'ils existent encore aujourd'hui.
C'est qu'ils sont pratiqués, ils sont
encore très vivants. Donc il faut transmettre
ces informations-là à nos enfants.
Il faut leur montrer aussi comment, justement,
les lois, et quand on va en cour aussi,
c'est fait pour éteindre ces droits-là.
Donc comment combattre ces outils qui sont
utilisés pour détruire les droits ancestraux.
Dans l'angle réconciliation,
il faut aussi éduquer
la population non autochtone sur ces droits-là
parce qu'ils ignorent tout des droits ancestraux.
Ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi on a des droits de chasse, de pêche,
de cueillette qui sont très différents
de ceux des Canadiens. Et, pour qu'il y ait
une réconciliation véritable,
il faut qu'il y ait une reconnaissance,
une restitution des territoires
et de de notre pratique ancestrale
pour qu'il y ait une véritable
réconciliation.
Alors, Stéphanie, je te souhaite bonne chance parce que c'est un travail énorme et ça demande beaucoup
d'éducation non seulement au sein de nos
communautés mais ça demande de l'éducation
aussi au sein
des communautés environnantes.
N'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo
et n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des questions.
Je vous souhaite une très belle semaine
à Parole autochtone.